[Music]
alright time once again for our matinee
show
this is matinee episode number 53 yeah
now this one we're doing let's see we're
gonna do the first episode of the new
creep show series yeah that has
premiered on shudder that's good well
probably actually do we'll probably do
each episode like each week except it's
gonna be like a little bit behind
because we actually record these on
Friday afternoon and they premiere the
new ones on Friday night yeah you know
what I mean
so we're gonna be doing episode one on
this one then we're gonna do a Netflix
movie and then we're gonna do a theater
maybe so that's where we're going with
this week's matinee show so the first
thing we're gonna talk about as I said
is the first episode of the brand-new
creep show series that premiered on
shudder on September 26 it was good it
lived up to creep show I was super
pumped about this I had been like seeing
seeing the trailers for it and I was
like so excited when I saw like all the
people that were gonna be working on it
and you know I really hoped that they
would honor the original Organon
anthology and stuff like that and they
really really did that and I am super
excited to see the rest of them yeah
writing was good quality the the way the
shot was great they even did the
animated transitions and stuff it was
just like just like that first movie
better actually yeah it's like you know
what I mean it really is in the same
spirit as the original Creepshow movie
um it the showrunner of these obviously
Greg Nicotero which means you're gonna
get not only because he you know work
came up under Tom Savini like back in
the 80s and [ __ ] like that you know we
before even he got famous with the
walking dead and everything but he
worked with Romero he worked on all
these things and he's a big practical
effects guy which i think is really
gonna be yeah a really cool thing and so
he did actually design the creep in this
one that's in like the wraparound
segments and you know unlike the creep
show too in the movie where it was like
animated which I didn't really like all
that much you know if you go back and
look at our review of creep show 2 which
was all right but you know obviously not
as good as the first one but this one
they went back to what the original
creep looked like in the original creepy
a movie and they've also got a really
beautiful just the cold comic book
transitions like you know it has like
animated pages like you know flipping
over
like you know little things that say
like you know two weeks later and yeah
things like that just like out of the
comic books and just like the original
movie yeah first the first story and it
was kinda light reminding me the one
that Stephen King was in with the mold
that took over him yeah kind of like
that Lonesome death attorney yeah this
is know about slime molds just eating
everything it takes over the guy and he
makes him a drunk Condor he was it I
don't really know how drunk he's a drunk
before but the fungus got on him and
turned him into some gray slime and he
started to divide and he was eating all
the cats and started eating all the
children and he started to divide can't
you know kind of like and the division
started to divide so it was kind of like
something out of the thing it was gonna
take over the earth and how long six
days six days yeah that's pretty good
which it was just yeah so what they're
gonna do I guess I'm I'm under I'm led
to understand that every single I think
there's going to be six episodes of
creep show in the first season but
they're each gonna have two stories yeah
second stories about a little girls
playing with her doll house and she sees
a little decapitated head of a doll and
there's a spooky-looking head and then
every time she looks and you shouldn't
see the dolls move but every time she
looks in something different happened
like they were running from a dog
running from the head of the heads
coming out and they started getting
killed and then the cop shows up it's
pretty cool yeah pretty cool I don't
want to spoil them yeah we're not gonna
spoil them but um you know I will say so
okay so the first story that's in it is
based on Stephen King short story gray
matter which was actually first
published in Cavalier magazine because
he used to get up you know back in the
old days he used to like go for magazine
important magazine stuff so it was
actually first post in 1973 and then
later it was published in this anthology
right here mine's very beat up as you
can see a night shift which came out in
1978 so it's based on this story gray
matter it's very similar to the source
material which I actually reread before
we did this because the very short story
it's only like four or five pages I
think the only things they changed were
they made the dad a little bit more
sympathetic in the Creepshow version
they also made it a hurricane instead of
a snowstorm just various things like
that you will note that there you know
Stephen King fans will probably like
squeal with delight because there are
really
a lot of Easter eggs in this I mean
that's not even saying that in the
opening credits of the show there's
actually a callback to the crate from
the first Creepshow movie and in the
first segment of this if you go through
there's like all these little missing
posters you know what I mean like on
this thing in the store and there's like
missing Church the cat missing Cujo the
dog the two girls that are that are
missing and the thing are the Grady
twins you know [ __ ] like that and then
when Timmy who is like the boy that's
supposed to be coming to this store to
like get his dad's beer in the middle of
the storm he comes in wearing a yellow
raincoat just like Georgie and it
there's like [ __ ] about like weird [ __ ]
going on in the sewers which actually
comes right from the story but that's
also kind of a you know an offhand
reference to it so there's a lot of that
kind of stuff like to spot in it I
really did like this story like Adrienne
Barbeau is in it which is nice callback
to the first one's doing pretty good
yeah she she is like the owner of the
store that like talks to Timmy and he's
like telling her about what's been
happening with his dad did not start did
not co-star her boobs though yeah no we
didn't get to see her boobs yeah she's
like but yeah so you get to see and
there's also like some other you know
kind of famous people in this like Tobin
Bell who it's you know obviously post
jigsaw and the jigsaw movies Aaron the
Saw movies rather that one the other
actor that's in this that's like one of
the other guys what the hell is his name
Giancarlo Esposito he's actually
probably best known nowadays for being
in Breaking Bad and better call Saul but
he was also in Maximum Overdrive so
there's another little Stephen King
callback for you there so this story
it's more like a monster movie type
story it's very simple there are only
about 15-20 minutes long like each
segment it was a good kickoff to the new
series oh definitely and that was the
store to show yeah because it doesn't
have not a complicated store it's just
scary monster yeah basically it's just
this kid comes and he says you know it's
my dad who was a drunk I mean obviously
you could read it and I think Stephen
King wrote it I mean it's pretty clear
if you read this
story as well that it's kind of like a
metaphor for alcoholism like a lot of
his stories were where it's like alcohol
is just like slowly turning this guy's
this kid's dad into a monster the story
itself is a lot like the one from the
first Creepshow movie that it is king in
the damn green moss everywhere from
outer space very much like that but just
has taken to new new levels and it looks
a lot better yeah and like I said I
think 99% of the effects in this are
practical effects as far as I'm aware
because as I said it's um you know it's
Greg Nicotero and his special effects
team working on it it's a lot more
sinister almost like something out of a
lien yeah and the monster is like it
looks really good and like it the
special effects are very gooey and like
glorious and [ __ ] like that like see it
again actually yeah I actually watched
it two times like for this review
because I wanted to like make sure um so
yeah so that was the first story now the
second one is called the house of the
head and it was based on a short story
by Josh malar Minh who else who also
wrote bird box and it was directed by
John Harrison who directed tales from
the dark side the movie which a lot of
people considered the third Creepshow
just because the real movie called
Creepshow 3 is so terrible because it
didn't have anything really to do with
the other two this is living up to the
Creepshow name though it definitely is
like I said the whole look of it now I
have to say of the two stories I didn't
realize but like the little girl that
plays Evie in the second segment that's
the little girl that plays Judith on The
Walking Dead now it's like oh dad I
thought she looked familiar but like
this one is a lot less gory but I
actually liked this one better just
because I mean her and like nothing it's
kind of like the whole thing takes place
inside a dollhouse which gives it a
slightly bit of like a hereditary type
of thing because they had that going on
but just the fact that you don't see
like all the stuff that happens in her
house like and I thought it was adorable
that the little family that she has
living in this dollhouse she calls them
the Smith Smith's that's their name okay
you know I mean I'm like that's so like
kid like and so this little hit this
little zombie head that appears in the
house and it's like every time she walks
away from the dollhouse like [ __ ] moves
around you like you never see it moving
yeah well it's
she just looks back in as a kid it's
changed like it's different tableau
something that's happening and you don't
see it like that's right--we're to blow
yeah yeah and there yeah and you don't
see it in action you see it in
freeze-frame this is a cool touch and I
like that like I because it really kind
of like ramped up the suspense because
even you didn't see anything going on in
there but it's like you knew that
something was gonna be different and
like you had to see it and then she's
like trying to help this by the police
she buys a policeman and then like a
doughnut priest well no it's not a pree
actually he buys shamon it was it was a
Native American and I said oh please
please make it old old cheap wooden head
from appreciate to what it was and I was
like super excited also what I she
wanted a priest originally but they
didn't have they didn't have one in this
store guy goes wolf you want a holy man
why don't you just take him and it was
like we have some Native American yeah
you're very spiritual people he said it
was kind of like a little joke yeah but
um yeah so it was old chief wooden head
there's also and I haven't seen a lot of
reviewers mention this and maybe I'm the
only person that's like crazy enough
that it noticed but inside Effie's
dollhouse was the was a little bitty
that little green marble ashtray
from the first movie yeah it was a rumor
in father's day which was the first one
in the first little callbacks in history
yes which was the first one in the first
movie that was what you know Bedelia had
bashed in her father's head with and
then that ashtray appeared at every
subsequent segment of creep show yeah
without them really calling attention to
it it was just kind of like an easter
egg in that so now this is like an
easter egg calling back to that Easter
Egg so it's like I met at Easter egg but
it's like a little bitty one and it's
just like in there for a couple of
seconds and I was like hey there's that
ashtray you know it's all shutter
exclusive we called it man when we first
started getting that shutter that
shutter subscription yeah I had a good
feeling about shutter yeah and now
they're becoming kind of like a major
player and this series right here and
hit it out of the park there's gonna be
great series I feel like it is - I 5
bucks a moderate for five bucks a month
yeah me shudder
you really can't it's like they have so
much good [ __ ] on their pen good stuff
of classic stuff and like I said
now they've started to do their own
thing you know you can tell that this is
made like I'm kind of a small budget but
it's like look at all the [ __ ] talent
they got in this and actually they're
going to do you know we're just gonna
watch the the series as it comes out I
kind of like that they didn't dump the
whole series on there at once they're
doing it weekly you know what I mean so
people will be discussing it one at a
time which i think is kind of neat um
but I feel like some of the upcoming
stuff like they're gonna do like a Joe
Hill story they're gonna do like Joe
Lance Dale Tom Savini is going to direct
one and [ __ ] like that so I feel like
this is gonna I have a really good
feeling about I like it a lot better
than Netflix just saying it has that
they understand the eighties retro yeah
they're going with it it they would eat
it would even be better if stranger
things was done by shudder they haven't
just fit right into what shudder does
yeah that's trail that would fit right
into their little world but you know
Netflix has it yeah it's a good series
too you know and we have Netflix yes we
have both its Netflix is good for like
generous um you know they have like a
lot of good like you know serial killer
documentaries they have like some series
and comedies and stuff like that but you
know if you're into horror and stuff
like that I mean just any retro [ __ ]
yeah because they have a lot of like
older classic [ __ ] like a lot of class
and like weirder [ __ ] that you don't see
otherwise like they have like a lot of
weird cult classics that you wouldn't
necessarily wring it back they're
bringing it back and basically blu-ray
quality yeah and and you know if not DVD
quality well in the best quality they
can yeah because some that stuff is you
know I'm terrible film stock from the
70s yeah but even even the [ __ ] and
Hammer horror films look [ __ ] good I
was gonna say they just recently added
like three a little bit lesser-known
Hammer movies and I definitely think
we're we need to review yeah me and
jenni just you know all the Victorian
boob outfit they knew what they were
doing the British [ __ ] do it well
they're they're very tip cetera you got
to be a high with [ __ ] boobs being a
hammer yeah and every single scene is
just gonna be like hey Wow
everything they just said that they know
exactly what they're doing but yeah so
seriously if you don't have shudder you
should probably get it because that this
series is totally worth it and they have
like a bunch of other good [ __ ] on there
too but like I said this was only the
first you know episode I actually liked
the house of the head probably a little
bit better than gray matter but they're
very different which i think is kind of
cool because I think they're kind of
showing that like look at all the
different styles of horror we're gonna
do like it's kind of playing up the
diversity of storytelling that they're
gonna do because the two stories you
know it's like a gooey monster thing and
then like a more sedate kind of
psychological horror type of thing so I
thought that was kind of cool that they
had just these two drastically different
styles and I kind of hope they keep that
up because I think that's one of the
strengths of the horror genre as a whole
it can do so much with it yeah and and I
think it's good that they are kind of
highlighting that so yeah definitely
check out the new creep show series I
like I said we're recording this on
Friday and I think a new one will be up
later tonight so we'll probably be
watching that we'll probably review that
on next Sunday show two on matinee 54
you
okay and the second movie we're going to
talk about was actually a 2009 teen
movie that appeared on Netflix earlier
recently it is called headcount now this
one it is the directorial debut of a
woman named al Callahan she actually had
has worked in the industry for a very
long time she was like a production
designer a production assistant or
someone like some Marvel movies like
ant-man and Avengers age of Ultron I
think she worked on Wonder Woman she
worked on stuff like that but this is
her directorial debut now it's kind of
it's said in Joshua Tree like out in the
desert and stuff and it's kind of about
these two brothers one of whom is named
Evan and one of whom is named Peyton now
Evan goes to visit his brother Peyton
who lives in the trailer out in the
desert he's kind of like a hippyish
straightedge type of dude so not much
really much fun so they go hiking
there's kind of like some tension
between them that they don't it's left
kind of ambiguous as to like kind of
what happened I guess their parents are
dead and like Peyton was kind of like a
father figure to the younger brother and
stuff but there's some kind of
undisclosed like kind of [ __ ] in their
past and they're trying to like work it
out so they go on a hike one day and it
turns out that they come across this
large group of people I think it's like
9 or 10 other people that are like
students and they're kind of they've are
also been out hiking in Joshua Tree and
they're out like drinking and smoking
pot and everything like that and Evan
decides because one of the girls is
particularly attractive and single that
he would rather hang out with them so he
kind of ditches his brother now as it
happens these nine or ten people have
rented this house and they're staying
there for like the weekend or a week or
whatever and their whole thing is you
know they're just they go back to the
house they're doing like tequila shots
they have all kind of drugs they have
like you know so it's like the party
house now another thing they do too is
after all the drinking and drugs is
they're all sitting around outside of
the campfire and stuff and they're
telling each other scary stories and
stuff like you do
so Evan decides that or they tell Evan
it's his turn to tell one if he can't
think of one so they tell him to go to
this website called anonymous nightmares
calm which is kind of like a creepypasta
type of thing and they said you know
just pick one at random and read it so
it turns out that the one he reads is
kind of like this weird poem about a
thing called
his G our history and it turns out that
it's sort of uh-oh a demon summoning
like a shining shell now this movie I
will say it's not it's not a slasher
it's not gory it's not anything the
movie it's strongly strongly reminded me
of was it follows so if you really like
that movie you will probably it's this
was not as good as that but it
definitely like reminded me of that
because of the way it kind of goes is
that it's very very subtle and like a
lot of the creepy [ __ ] is happening like
in the background or like in the fringes
of thing and it's not like really you
know focused in on so you have to kind
of be paying attention to all the [ __ ]
that's going on in the background to
like see what's happening because it
takes a while to like for you to realize
that what the history does is that it
the thing in the rhyme about it's like
it's something you've already seen or
something like that so basically it
takes over another person and makes like
a copy of them so there's all this like
creepy [ __ ] where they'll be in the
house and there's like somebody and then
they'll walk into the room and then
you'd like you look back and they're
still in that room so there's like two
of them and then and Evan is like
freaking out because he's not really
sure because he doesn't really know
these people and he makes a joke like
early on about like how he can't really
tell one from the other he could he or
he couldn't like remember like how many
of them there were
so four it takes a while for him to like
realize that some of these people are
not who they seem to me and the thing
about the history too is I guess it like
when it takes people over it makes them
like suicidal it's like some kind of
like I said it's like a demonic curse
type of thing I actually really liked
this movie like I said if it's very much
like it follows it reminded me a little
bit of a movie called compliance not
compliance coherence so if you actually
you should check that out because that's
really good too in the sense that it's
done like is a really low budget and it
plays a lot with kind of doppelganger
type of imagery and like you know
doubled like that kind of unsettling
creepy thing and the way it reminds me
of it follows is where because you know
and it follows the thing that was coming
after you like looked like a person but
you never knew who it was but you were
the only one who could see it but it was
always like happening in the background
so this there is very much like that
like I said I don't think it's
successful as it follows or coherence
but I definitely think it's you know I
think this is that she's gonna be a
director to watch because this is
actually really really good for a
first-time director as I said if you're
into like you know monster movies or
anything like that it is very subtle you
know it's more of a psychological kind
of drama it takes a while and like I
said you really have to be paying
attention to like the [ __ ] that's going
on the background the only like quibble
I would give is that not a lot of
characterization because the cast is so
large they can't really focus a lot on
any of the characters so a lot of this
stuff is kind of left but in a way that
kind of works in its favor because like
I said the Evan character doesn't know
any these people either and he says oh I
can't tell one from the other and like
so maybe like it put kind of puts the
audience in the same situation as him
like you know you can't tell one person
the other the only other quibble is that
I kind of wish they hadn't shown the
history at all because they did kind of
show it briefly at the end and I kind of
wish they had kind of not done that
because I think it's better like left
ambiguous and you didn't really know
what it looked like because it just kept
taking over other people's ship forms it
wasn't my kind of movie really yeah I
think he kind of got bored with it yeah
it didn't it didn't catch my attention
and it didn't keep it it was you know I
don't you know this movie really I'm not
the target audience to you gonna mean I
think mostly younger people would really
be into this it's like hearing a bunch
of teenagers just talk about this [ __ ]
and yeah and young people talk about
this [ __ ] I don't really care about it
it didn't really nothing about the movie
really jumped out grabbed me early on to
make me want to continue watching it
yeah my mind started to wander yeah and
then as nothing really started nothing
you know nothing really started to
happen for me you know I mean I just
forgot to forgot that I was watching the
movie yeah that's that's how that [ __ ]
went and like I said this it's not a bad
movie it's just yeah it's just not the
kind of monster movie I'd watch well it
like I said this is definitely the
a thing where you definitely have to pay
attention and and honestly I probably
would want to watch it a second time
because I'm sure there's a lot of [ __ ]
because I think a lot of [ __ ] happened
earlier that you kind of miss if you're
not really paying attention because a
lot like I said a lot of shits going on
to the background and it's that it's
very subtly kind of done which I like
but you know she's working with a
limited budget so there wasn't much she
could do so she had to tailor a story
around what she had yes so it was it's
good you know technically it was good
yeah yeah and in a way it reminded on
wellness it reminded me a lot of
coherence where which was basically just
shot in one house which was actually the
directors house he shot it in his own
house with a bunch of improvised actors
which just goes to show that if you have
a good concept you don't need a lot of
money you only need one concept for one
location you know and you can like make
a really compelling narrative out it
wasn't quite enough action I mean you
know I mean yeah it's a slow burn look
at Mandy Mandy wasn't high quote you
know it wasn't a big-budget movie but
man that [ __ ] was exciting yeah you
know just plus the visuals of that was
yeah it's so crazy that yeah but that
that's a possibility so a movie like
this has to compete against up somewhat
with something like that yeah yeah I'm
in and she can it's just that she didn't
in this well like I said this her first
time out and I thought this was actually
a really good movie first time out like
I said it's not as good as it follows
even though it reminded me very strongly
of that but I'm kind of like you know I
want to see what she does in the future
because yeah I like I like these kind of
movies yeah you know it was the
quality's good it's just that if you
haven't if you don't have any money this
story better be [ __ ] wild yeah yeah
not I mean yeah that's my that's my
advice
yeah and you know she can do it just
keep at it yeah most most directors you
know don't don't really knock it out of
the park for the first few movies you
know yeah that's true yeah I mean you
know with like everything else it's a
learning but you know watch it you know
if you're in a slow burn kind of movies
it's yeah you probably really dig if
like I said if you're willing to kind of
give it your full attention cuz there's
a lot of [ __ ] going on a lot of little
detail in the fringes and little I'm
kind of a like a lazy watcher yeah he's
usually like doing other [ __ ] if there's
another [ __ ] if it doesn't really grab
my attention I'm back on it
tablet yeah I got brothers [ __ ] to do
it's got to be something that just takes
over yeah like oh wow hold on what
really Oh where's this go up you know
that's you know yeah but that's the
standard now you know all movies said if
you're not in theater you're gonna be
competing against the real world
yeah and you know we go to the DMC
theater all the time it's watched boring
ass movies we stop to go when all the
time we really only see one a week now
well because we decided to like stop
forcing ourselves to watch stuff that we
weren't really interested I'm not saying
that those aren't good movies I'm just
saying that they're not we're not
interested but I'm not really interested
most dog movies and don't want to see
you know all the key all the children's
that's what I mean I don't you know I
like some animated movies but I don't
they yeah I don't want to see like
religious as you guys okay it's like I
don't want to see stuff like aimed at
tweens or anything you know but yeah
seriously if you're into like subtle
slow burn horror if you liked it follows
then probably you should check this out
it is on Netflix right now
all right and the third movie we're
gonna talk about we've been looking
forward to this one for a really long
time this one's Joker yeah it's gonna be
an easy one glad to see it movie this
honestly was amazing I think you know
what if Joaquin Phoenix doesn't get an
Oscar for this then I mean for sure he's
gonna get nominated he's got to I mean I
his ass off his performance in this was
just like and he was in every scene
pretty much right I mean yeah that I can
remember so weird movie because it's not
really a comic book movie as you would
know it it feels like a gritty New York
crime movie in a way where a score says
like the 70s yeah very taxi driver very
King of Comedy very mean streets yeah
it's weird and you don't know what's
real in this movie so the movie's being
seen through the eyes of a narrator you
can't really trust his grip on reality
yeah and there's a bunch of [ __ ] that
happens and you know has all the
elements of the Joker that you would
know from the Batman mythos but a
slightly different take on it and you
just don't know if everything that
happens in this movie is true or not
because this is Allu yeah well lunatic
that you're dealing with in a way I kind
of love that they did that because yes
they used some elements from the 1988
graphic novel The Killing Joke
particularly the part where Joker says
that he prefers his past to be multiple
choice yeah so I think they kind of took
that ran with it and it's like the thing
about it is that that there are some
hints in it that things didn't happen
the way because like I said you're
seeing everything essentially through
the character of Arthur Fleck um you
know played by Joaquin Phoenix so you
don't know it he's clearly mentally
unstable rocks you can trust his right
and there is some clearly in you know
early in the movie there's some clearly
some [ __ ] that is imagined and they
showed that he's imagining it like it
happened like that so you actually don't
know how much of the movie actually
happened or how much
how much of it is real how much of it
was his perception of an event or did he
just imagine the entire event at the end
you find out there were whole elements
of the story that weren't true right and
then you see certain things that happen
and that kind of happened in a way
that's very improbable so after you find
out that there was an element of untruth
in all this or it's a hallucination you
can look back on it and go did it really
happen that way or said this way he
remembered it for instance he goes on a
talk show and talks for a long time on
this damn talk show and it's a very odd
subject matter that they're talking on
and in reality you couldn't go on that
long without being kicked off the show
yes so did it really go down that way or
did he just imagine that it went down
that way bunch of weird [ __ ] happens and
well the thing that I think is so
brilliant about this movie is that not
only does it make you question the
reality because it's putting you in the
shoes of someone with a horrible mental
illness it's also kind of like it's
making you sympathize with him because
you know a lot of bad [ __ ] happens to
him so you can understand like why he
acts the way he does like why he cracks
and why he acts out the way he does but
it doesn't glorify it it doesn't justify
it it doesn't say yeah that's what you
should do yeah because he's obviously
he's a villain he's obvious but it's
humanizing him in a way that you can
relate to him while not condoning his
actions and I think it's a fine line to
walk but I think they really really did
that and there's certain aspects of like
Batman lore that yeah shows you things
that have happened in other movies but
they're different yeah for instance
everybody knows if you watch even watch
the old Batman that Joker shoots down
and kills
Bruce Wayne's parents yeah they have a
scene that's like that in this movie but
it's not Joker that shot the parents
down yet somebody dressed up like the
Joker yeah during a riot but you have to
ask yourself
what's the chances what's the chances
that's just Joker hallucinating as
somebody else did it right like I said
you can't trust anything trust it yeah
so everything is up for grabs and then
the way the movie ends it ends with a
scene that makes you kind of question
the reality of the whole damn movie but
like it might be an alternate
explanation for for what Joker how Joker
was created yeah it's so it's very meta
that's what I think it's so brilliant
there's so much like ambiguity there's
like little clues and little hints left
of this that the other thing but it's
like it could go either way and I'm
blood and I like that they didn't
resolve something yeah they left it open
to interpretation and in this movie
Joker has an entirely different
perspective of Bruce Wayne's dad what
was what was that big Wayne what's his
honest way
Thomas Wayne that's right he has a
totally different viewpoint or a version
of Thomas Wayne and you have to ask
yourself is that the way Thomas Wayne
really is or is that just the way Joker
is that being Slee is for saving him
yeah see she just don't know and it's
not done in any kind of corny way you
know I mean this is not corny at all not
corny at all this is like very uh almost
sucking like it's a masterpiece it's
like something Kubrick would make that's
what I mean and like I said a lot of
people have you know compared this to I
mean and obviously Todd Phillips the
director who previous to this only two
comedies he did like the hangover movies
and old school and stuff but he is
clearly a huge Scorsese fan and he has
come out right and you know said that
taxi driver was a big influence the King
of Comedy was a big influence in Robert
De Niro's in this which is kind of a
callback to that there even like some
direct callbacks to taxi driver like the
whole gun to the head gesture like some
of the shots I don't think it's like a
ripoff it's kind of an homage sure you
know it's in a similar kind of vein but
it you know it's just kind of this this
thing of where you're taking this really
damaged character and are just kind of
like putting you inside it's a it's not
a fun movie at all it's like you know
what I mean but it's a really compelling
movie and to be honest there were some
scenes in it
um we're particularly the scene with
with Joker and the his co-worker and the
little person like in the apartment I'm
not gonna spoil it or anything but that
scene was like super super tense because
Arthur Fleck as a character is so
unbalanced that you never know exactly
what he's going to do in any given
situation so you're just like on edge
like through the whole thing because you
don't know how he's gonna react to
different stimuli and you don't know
what's true like for instance you know
the the Heath Ledger Joker
yeah and that move in that Dark Knight
movie everything he would tell different
stories of how his face got that way yes
each story was totally different yeah
the way you take in that movie is that
he's lying yeah but there's another way
to look at it maybe he Joker himself had
three or four different memories of how
that happened right all of them false
but equally true to him yeah and imagine
that Joker or that this joker is do
telling you his story by directing this
movie that's probably a good way that
was kind of the vibe I got but actually
the right like after I left and like
thought about it you got a guy who's
trying to tell you his story through his
movie all right of the history of the
Joker and he doesn't know it's true
there's a bunch of [ __ ] that could be
true maybe not you don't know it could
be this or it could be that or it could
be both or neither cuz it seems you
don't realize it at the time that you're
watching the movie but as it unfolds you
realize that there's a lot of
inconsistencies in this tale well this
is that like the different essential
unreliable narrator exactly
quintessential yeah I mean because you
have and like and like you said he might
be so mentally ill that he doesn't know
right or he has two or three different
versions right of say for instance who
his dad was or who you know or what his
child a child like or what his child
upbringing was like there maybe three or
four different versions of that exactly
that's why I mean you know kind of like
the Heath Ledger Joker had three or four
different versions of how his face got
that way
yeah you know he may not been a lie and
he just had four different ways yeah you
said that in the comic book Killing Joke
that Joker said his history or his past
was multiple choice he look prefer it to
be mold with it and that's what this is
this movie is multiple choice yeah
and like I said a lot of the things are
left and big yes and I liked that about
I think yeah probably its greatest
strength because these conundrums and
these would cut what do you call it they
it's almost kind of like a mobius strip
this is what's driving Joker crazy yeah
that yeah well isn't that all these
multiple choice things what it could be
yeah he's [ __ ] up and in a way too
it's like I know that was kind of like
um some people talking about like you
know the violence in this and everything
like that not that violent really well
no but it's the thing about it is like
there's not a lot of violence in it but
the violence it's in it and the way it's
portrayed is actually very impactful and
a disturbing makes you feel it's real in
a way that like makes usually be like oh
you know what I mean and in a way I got
that I mean the whole theme of the movie
I thought was that you know people are
going through their own [ __ ] and so
everyone should be civil to everyone
else because you never know what someone
else is going through and if you're a
[ __ ] to that person one day it might
come back to bite you in the ass you
know what I mean so it seemed like there
was a lot of that going on - so I kind
of got more of a vibe of you know quit
being shitty to people because you don't
know what [ __ ] they're going through but
at but as you said there's also kind of
a larger theme to of like Joker's
history and how he perceives it yeah if
this is how it actually happened you
know you want and things like that come
out of the movie and you're not you
don't know what Joker's life was really
like you don't know what Wayne was
really like you don't and neither does
the Joker yeah because it's all through
his it's all through his [ __ ] up
perception and he is clearly a very
mentally ill / yeah what makes it great
is that it's not done in some kind of
corny way using weird special effects or
flashbacks or dream sequences no you
can't tell what is real and what is it
it's all presented as reality yeah
this is a very grounded maybe I would
like yes it's in about a quote-unquote
comic-book character but this is not
like a comic movie at all there's no
special effects there's no nothing like
that it's basically like a character
study the I have to say like the
cinematography of like Gotham City which
was obviously mostly filmed in New York
and Jersey City and Newark and stuff um
looks great like it's almost like a
character on its own just like in taxi
driver if you keep in mind when you
watch in the movie just pretend that the
director and the writer of this story
itself is the Joker you can't then it
starts to make a lot more sense yeah I
have to say to that like I said it makes
sense it's just that it makes even more
sense on different dimensions yes you
realize that you're being told a story
by an unroll and insane narrator yeah I
have to say too that um you know I think
I already said that like Joaquin Phoenix
you should for real get an Oscar for
this because he's just like amazing but
also one of the things one he lost 50
pounds for this so he cuz and you can
really see it like when it's like you
can see his spine at his shoulder blade
sticking out and stuff like that he's
weird-looking do the shoulders the
physicality well that's why because he
lost so much weight for this yeah the
physicality of his role like you can
even see like not only in his facial
expression selective but the way his
body moves the way he walks and stuff
like that as the story goes on and
arthur fleck becomes the joker in the
sense that he's finding his power i
guess or finding his confidence what you
want to call it if that's what you want
to call it like in a fucked-up way
that's what he's doing like he's kind of
finding his calling or owning his crazy
I guess you is the way I put it
yesterday but it's just the way his
whole movements change is really amazing
to watch yeah now there's a lot of
difference though between the Joker and
this movie and other jokers yeah this is
a sure different take oh yeah I mean
this Joker is the origin story Joker
he's not physically imposing he's not
intimidating really but he's destructive
yeah you know because they're getting
killed disturbed yeah yeah
but he's not he's not like your cartoon
supervillain at this point no and he's
not something he's not this kind of like
Sigma male kind of you know super
villain with henchmen and you know
expertise in making bombs and having
military skills he's not like that not
yet if he's just like a regular guy with
a royal problem real broken loser who's
just started [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up and
it's just by the nature of just how
[ __ ] up he is that people get [ __ ]
up not really a winner he's a pretty
much a loser at this point but he's he
did become the Joker very realistic yeah
because ocher would really be that's
what I mean it was like you know in real
life like sometimes people if you
already got like mental problems stuff
and you just keep getting [ __ ] on and
[ __ ] on and [ __ ] on by life I mean
eventually you that person's gonna crack
and I think that that's kind of what
this was exploring I would love to see a
sequel to this movie I know I don't know
if they're gonna do one but it's like it
would be awesome and way I would do it
is later okay
the Joker is older and Batman is now old
enough to fight against him and your
experience and Batman through the eyes
of the Joker yeah an experience yeah I
made it actually experiencing Batman
through the eyes of the Joker he would
see the [ __ ] Batman as a dick
really yeah as a jock boy dick who was
picking on him yeah and [ __ ] who owed
him some [ __ ] yeah and that I'd like to
see Batman
you would see bad man he would see
Batman in a very poor light well yeah
because that's how Joker was here's the
thing about it and this I think like
just stands in film as a whole the best
villains the most compelling villains
are villains that are heroes in their
own perception yeah Joker thinks he's a
[ __ ] good guy
yes he's nice right and he's clearly not
like from our point of view he's a
villain and he think anybody associated
with the wait with the Wayne's or
[ __ ] yeah you know I mean and so I
can that's the wit that's the next joke
a movie I want to see you wanna see
Batman is
can dick yeah that would be funny yeah I
would actually really like this like I
said you know this it's it's different
than any other comic book movie it's
definitely much more like a like a
gritty 70 s character study like a
psychological study of a broken man and
how that can kind of turn into various
things and like I said it also has this
whole meta at angle of like unreliable
narrator you're not really sure like
what's real and what's not because
there's definitely things that happen in
there that later on you find out aren't
real I also want to point out the
[ __ ] amazing score to this movie why
the music choices are great results but
the score of this [ __ ] would happen in
DePaul and I so I looked up the ice like
who did the score for this it's a it was
an she's an Icelandic musician and I'm I
can't pronounce her name it's Hilde her
goodnight dear I guess I'm sure I bet
you're butchered that really bad but
she's like a musician she's a classical
cellist has also worked with robbing
gristle so I thought that was kind of
Awesome but yeah she did the score for
this and it is amazing and also like a
lot of the music choices they made were
amazing also they use like a lot of like
old-timey this is the movie set in 1981
actually but they use like a lot of
really old timey songs you know like
[ __ ] Bing Crosby and that kind of
stuff which I thought worked really well
and also there was that whole you know
the whole thing with the with the talk
show like that Robert De Niro said very
much like Johnny Carson so this is very
much like that late seventies early
eighties like talk shows circuit another
thing is if the movie kind of starts off
kind of slow it does go on like this I'm
boring I'm this is cool but it's kind of
boring but it builds up pretty quickly I
mean it just shows how this guy's gonna
lose his [ __ ] mind yeah you know I
mean it's a great movie this you know
there there's there's controversy about
it on Ron Tomatoes you know and they're
talking about all this in stuffs I
didn't see any hint of any of this in
sell [ __ ] you know what I mean it's
it's it's a great movie I thought it was
there it thought it was a masterpiece of
what it is it's like a Scorsese film
yeah it's up there with like a Kubrick
film it's up there with the shining and
everything
just a good [ __ ] movie yeah it's just
anyway there's something weird about it
nowadays this movie stands out as being
something kind of unusual but back in
the day this would have been just kind
of a normal movie well yeah they made it
like I said early 70s there was a lot of
it a lot of this yeah it's war there was
like anti-heroes or yeah or where there
were like psychological studies of like
bad people yeah you know what I mean
even like a lot of the mob movies and
yeah just like that I mean a lot of
those characters were terrible yeah but
you watch them because they were
compelling right and now now that
they're kind of bringing that back it's
just like breath of fresh air really it
is yeah because the thing about it is
that you can enjoy watching a movie
about a terrible person yeah but not and
and even sympathize with that person and
see them as a human being but not
condone what that person is doing yes
your unknowns what Joker is doing it got
a lot of people you know on the
corporate media to try to pass judgment
on a movie as if it's some kind of a
[ __ ] moral statement that's not what
these movies are about movies are kind
of educational in a way they're showing
you stuff you go through an experience
so you can learn certain aspects to
reality through these things it's art
yeah it's art you know I mean and like I
said you can't even want to censor art
yeah and if anything one yes this movie
has violent you know a few violent
scenes in it but I don't think that
anyone at least not anyone in their
right mind would think that it was
admirable and to me like I thought those
the violent scenes for being like spaced
out I thought they were really well done
because they were really compelling and
like really upsetting and like
disturbing as they should be if you
actually look at it it's not that
violent a movie it's really not like I
said but but the fact that they spaced
it out like I said I think that's better
because it made it when it happened it
had a lot more impact Saving Private
Ryan was a lot more violent a lot of
obviously thousands of people dying in
that one it's yeah they're just getting
machines blown like that so it's not
play notes and like I said - I feel like
you know one of the central things about
this movie was that you know yes Arthur
flex character who would later become
Joker yes he did terrible things they
the movie wasn't asking you to like say
oh isn't it cool
that like he killed this person that
burned it wasn't saying that
I'm saying look what happens to a
damaged person when they keep getting
[ __ ] on in terms of violence that
actually put it up there may be like
Goodfellas yeah
about like that it was it was very
similar like I said was very similar to
more more effective audio effects and
[ __ ] you know man I was thinking that
too
yeah but you know because it was a
different it's a different era yeah and
do a lot more but you know if if you
were if you weren't grossed out by
Goodfellas then this wouldn't bother you
yeah and I'm not I'm not saying so much
I don't say violence is like you know
like gore cuz obviously I've seen like
wave yeah super gory movies it's not
gory or anything like that they're just
talking about you know violence in the
sense of like shooting even if you're
getting stabbed but like I said it's
about like Goodfellas yeah it's no worse
than that but you know like I said I
think that the scenes being spaced out
and being framed that way the way they
were framed actually made them really
effective in the sense that it made you
like because like I said you were
nervous because his character was so he
could kind of feel it coming yeah he was
so crazy and you weren't exactly sure
what was gonna happen because he was so
like unbalanced so it really kind of
kept you on the edge of your seat
there's certain people he let go but
your thing is is that after you get done
with a movie you're not sure whether you
can believe whether or not he let that
let certain people go when he did yeah
like I said it kind of makes you and
this is definitely making the question
this whole story when it's over you're
like this is definitely what I want to
see a second time yeah because there's
there's a lot of different reads to it
there's a lot of yeah ends and you're
like that motherfucker's why you could
read it as like a straight narrative
where you could read it like in a
completely different way and I think
that's good I think that's like
something that a lot of the best movies
have is like that's like different
interpretations right you know what I
mean like a shiny yeah that wasn't
that's what I was thinking of yeah and
like you're not wrong necessarily it's
no way look it's just another way of
looking at it and I think it's good that
like people can see what they want to
see in it you know what I mean so it
definitely you look at it the simple way
of what you were shown or you can look
at it the alternate way of that you
relied - well yeah and it was a and
fooled by another man's hallucinations
yeah it definitely leaves it open for
the duration is
really a good way to put it not in this
not what uh what's a better term than
hallucination it kind of like I think
you mentioned it before confabulation no
not really confabulation that's where
you can't alike change you see things
the way you want to see them yeah it's
yeah yeah like selective perception yeah
right and I think that's what it is
you know that's why I think a lot of the
movie is I kind of him leaning that way
to look I said I would like to see it a
second time just saying I'm like I said
him - we didn't spoil anything really in
this but def I would definitely lose you
know that's what I meant yeah you're
seeing his delusions I think yeah I know
I know some of it is some of it is
delusion well yeah they don't make any
bones about yeah that's that's not
really sure how much of this is delusion
right yeah and I like I said I think
that's what makes this really
fascinating arms I loved this movie you
know your mileage may vary but I feel
like most I mean [ __ ] when it premiered
at the Venice Film Festival it got the
Golden Lion which is like the highest
prize you know I'm you know got its
standing ovations and everything like
that so like I'd actually clap in a
theatre when it was over I've heard that
from like other people you know but they
said people like applauded at the end
yeah I mean it was just a great year
Miriam
we haven't heard people applaud in a
long time I feel last month had applause
was John wick three didn't they kind of
didn't people I think they did yeah that
one
that was about the only one that past
year so that yeah but yeah I mean I
really loved this movie it's like super
it's disturbing it's very harrowing
Joaquin Phoenix like deserves an Oscar
for this because it's his performance
just like amazing I'm like not just his
facial expression the way acted but also
like the whole physicality of it oh you
gotta win an Oscar I mean yeah it's like
it'd be kind of sad if he didn't because
I mean he was amazing in this but yeah
definitely definitely go check it out
it's like no other comic book movie
you've ever seen I don't even know if I
would call it that but if you especially
if you like like old Scorsese movies all
the gritty 70s movies you will probably
be all over this but yeah I thought it
was really great so highly recommended
you